[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW SOLDO: First, just
a little bit about myself.
I've been working in the cloud
industry for a while now.
I started my career at
PayPal, moved on to Amazon,
got to see the differences
in how they built apps,
which was really interesting.
But I really wanted
the startup experience
that everybody comes
to Silicon Valley for.
And I stumbled upon this
crazy little company
called Heroku that was
doing what at the time
was called platform as
a service for Ruby apps.
And I had built a Rails
app for a failed startup.
And so I was this
weird person who
could make spreadsheets,
code in Ruby,
and maybe think about what
products people should build.
So I became a product manager
in the first dozen or so people
at Heroku.
Had a great run there.
It was a ton of fun.
Managed and started the
Heroku Postgres product,
which maybe some
of you have used,
and for a while PMed
the main Heroku product.
Then I left there, did
a couple of things,
spent a couple of
years at Docker.
And then I found my way
over to Google Cloud.
And so I'm PMing the App Engine
product, which is actually
Google Cloud's oldest product.
It predates Google Cloud.
And it had been the janky
old product in the portfolio.
But in the last couple of years,
we've been reinvesting in it.
And now, it's the really
cool vintage product
in the Google portfolio.
So I hope you folks
will be excited about it
and give it a try.
So you can post your
questions on Dory,
and I'll take a look
at them at the end.
I think you can link to
it from the NEXT app.
I don't know.
If not, you can use
this ugly URL here.
So what we're going
to cover today.
First, I'm going to
talk about just what
are your options for
Ruby on Google Cloud.
Then I'm going to
show you a basic app.
Basically, this is an app
Heroku circa 2013 or so.
Rails, Postgres,
and Redis running on
in a single location.
Then we're going to do something
that, frankly, I've always
wanted to do, which
is build an app that
spans multiple continents
and georoutes to them based
on where you are
and is resilient to
an entire continent going down.
It's ICBM-proof,
as I like to say.
OK, so first of all, if you
take one thing away from this,
it's this.
Ruby is now on App Engine
in a really big way.
We announced that yesterday
in the big mega blog
post about serverless.
We've got a whole
paragraph of mention.
It is an alpha.
I can say it has a
couple of rough edges,
but it's actually pretty
good for an alpha product.
I've been really
banging on it hard.
And it works, which is great.
So I will show a URL at the end
for how you folks can use it.
It is a private alpha.
But all you have to do
is join a Google Group,
and it'll magically
work for you.
OK, so let's talk about your
Ruby options on Google Cloud.
Before, there was
basically only one option,
which was App Engine Flex.
And for those of
you who might not
be too familiar with
App Engine, there's
basically two flavors
to environments.
There's Flex and Standard.
And it's kind of-- environment's
a bit of a misnomer.
They're basically completely
different products.
Completely different code bases,
different user interfaces.
App Engine Flex
used to be called
managed virtual machines.
And that's what it is.
It's basically like a
serverless-like experience
on virtual machines.
So scaling it out
takes 10 minutes
because you've got to wait for
the virtual machine to load.
Deploys take a while.
It abstracts some things away,
but it's not really serverless
because there are servers there.
So the choices were
kind of barren.
But now, oh my gosh, we
still have App Engine Flex.
But now we've got
App Engine Standard,
a second-generation runtime.
We've got Cloud Run,
which is just announced.
You can just create a container.
It can have Ruby in it.
Cloud Run doesn't care
what's in the container.
And it works.
Or you can do Cloud Run on GKE,
where you take that container
and run it on your own
private GKE cluster.
So lots of choices.
They all work pretty well.
It's a lot of fun.
Now I want to go--
oh-- OK, here we go.
So again, take a quick picture
of this if you want to try it.
This is a super-ugly URL,
appengine-standard-ruby25-alpha
Google Group.
You'll go to the
Google Groups, log in
with your Google account--
the same one you use
on Google Cloud--
join the group.
It's set to just auto
accept anybody who joins.
And that puts you
into the alpha.
And there will be a link there
to docs on how you use it.
But we'll be showing
you that today.
It's pretty straightforward.
Here's that Dory link again
if anybody has questions.
You can also ask questions live.
But if you're shy and don't
want to get up and talk,
you can just put it on your
app and do a question there.
All right.
So I want to show you
a simple Ruby app.
But actually, let's take a
detour and talk about why Ruby.
I'm actually curious.
Most people here are Rubyists.
If you just want to shout,
why do you program in Ruby?
Anybody.
AUDIENCE: It's easy.
MATTHEW SOLDO: It's easy.
I think it's super easy.
I pride myself on being
a really bad programmer.
And Ruby is a language that
makes a lot of sense to me.
Anyone else?
Why Ruby?
AUDIENCE: Rails.
MATTHEW SOLDO: What's that?
Using Rails.
MATTHEW SOLDO: Rails.
Yes, Rails is awesome.
It's not cool.
It is super not cool right now.
But I think it is awesome.
If you want to build a web app
that's backed by a database,
it's such a no-brainer.
You can create a
Rails app in a second.
You could fire up a scaffold.
Basically with a
couple of commands,
you could have a working app.
And I'm actually giving
a talk in about an hour,
talking about productivity
with serverless.
And to me, Rails and
serverless go hand-in-hand.
You can build an app
in under an hour.
And you can deploy it
in a couple of minutes.
And you can actually test out
to see if it's something useful,
which is great.
I also think Ruby is
great, and Rails too,
for expressing business
logic, like having a model.
You can have an invoice model.
Invoice.create
creates a new invoice.
Invoice.send.
You can create this code
that is very easy to read,
very business-friendly.
And I think it's
one of the best ways
to model business
logic out there.
And it turns out most apps
have that sort of logic in it.
All right.
So let's talk about
a simple Ruby app.
We're going to
use these things--
App Engine, Cloud SQL, Cloud
Memorystore, and VPC Connector.
So let me tell you about what's
changed in the Google Cloud
world on why this is relevant.
The janky old App Engine
of a couple of years
ago, it was this
all-in-one product.
It came with Datastore.
It came with a special
flavor of memcache.
It was memcacheg, for Google.
It was different from
regular memcache.
And those services
worked really well.
They worked perfectly
out of the box.
But if you wanted to use
something else, tough luck.
You couldn't.
You couldn't even get
direct network access.
You had to use a special
API called URL Fetch.
You wanted a different library?
You couldn't use it.
You could only get the
libraries that were on there.
And the language runtimes
themselves weren't even
the open source ones.
They were these special
forks of the languages
that Google maintained.
So in other words, it
was super proprietary.
But last year, we
released something
called second generation
runtimes, which is
what people expect these days.
It's a fully open
source language runtime.
Has direct network
access, obviously.
And so that was a
big step forward.
But the Ruby second
generation runtimes
run on an entirely
different cluster
from the rest of Google Cloud.
And they weren't able to talk
to a lot of the Google Cloud
services.
So also yesterday,
we released something
called VPC connectors.
And this completes the picture
for using App Engine second gen
runtimes and Ruby.
They let you connect to
any VM or any service built
on VMs, which is like
Cloud SQL or Redis, that's
running in Google Cloud.
So now you can use all
the parts of Google Cloud
along with your App Engine app.
And that's another big
takeaway that you should get,
is that Google Cloud
has all these fun toys--
AI, Artificial Intelligence
APIs, Redis, memcache, Spanner,
all these cool things.
And now with App
Engine you can actually
use them, which is great.
All right.
So it's pretty easy.
This is the bare bones setup.
In your gemfile
or wherever you're
specifying your Ruby gem, you
want to do 2.5.3 or greater.
It's currently
running Ruby 2.5.3,
and it's going to
be 2.5.5 shortly.
Maybe we'll go to 2.6.
We'll see.
App Engine has something
called an app.yaml.
That's where you
configure it and tell it
what it is you're doing.
You need to tell it you're
using the Ruby runtime.
You tell it an instance class.
There's F1, F2, and F4.
The F1 is 128 megabytes of RAM.
And it turns out that it's
not enough RAM to run even
most basic Ruby apps.
So you need to do an F2.
But I've got really good news.
And you guys are going to be
some of the first to hear it.
Later this quarter,
we're going to be
doubling the memory on all
of the second gen instances.
So you'll be able to use an F1
for the same price as the F2.
That F1 will be 256 megs, which
is enough for a basic Ruby app.
And finally, you set something
called an entry point.
And this is just the
command that gets run.
It could be a Rails
server command.
Or it can be a Puma command
directly, or whatever you want.
And then on the CLI, you just
type in gcloud app deploy.
That's assuming you've
got the gcloud client.
If you don't, just install it.
And boom, it should work.
All right.
So that would get you just
like a Hello World app.
But Hello World doesn't
really get you very far.
So you'll probably-- almost all
apps-- we talked about Rails.
Rails is great.
Rails usually wants a
relational database.
And it really likes Postgres.
That's my favorite.
So to set this up, just
click into the Cloud SQL
part of the Google console.
And you're going to
fill out this form here.
You give it some name.
Generate a password.
I have all those-- whoa.
Oh, yeah, OK.
I didn't step through this.
OK.
So yeah, you'll give it a--
you just click that Generate
Password button and copy that.
Pick a region.
You can choose to run it in
the US, west, central, or east.
Europe.
We've got lots and
lots of regions.
It's one of the really cool
things about Google Cloud.
And really important-- and this
is actually a little caveat I
ran into--
enable a public IP.
Otherwise, it
doesn't seem to work.
In theory, you should be
able to have a private IP
and connect via the VPC Connect.
But once we get that working,
we'll document that properly.
This is still alpha.
OK, then, one of
the cool things you
can do in that app.yaml--
this is an App Engine-specific
thing-- is you can set
environment variables.
So just set your-- that
password you generated,
just stick it in there.
Tell it what your user is.
And tell it what the host is.
That host, after this
screen, after you actually
click the Create, it'll
give you this host.
You just put out
the cloudsql dash.
There's this special unix socket
that gets created on App Engine
to connect to your
Cloud SQL instances.
And so that's actually
what it's doing.
And then in your Rails app
and in your database.yml,
you just reference those
environment variables
for setting up your database.
All right, now.
What I talked about before,
creating a VPC connector.
So by default, when you create
a project in Google Cloud,
you get a virtual private cloud
that has all the [INAUDIBLE]
stick VMs that are shielded
from the big, bad, dangerous
internet.
So it's real easy.
You just click into here.
You're going to have
to enable VPC access.
For some reason I don't get,
most of the products on Google
Cloud don't work by default. You
have to first enable the API.
Then you can use them.
I don't know why that is.
I'm sure there's a
good reason for it.
But it makes for awkwardness
in getting started.
OK, then you're going to click
into a serverless VPC access
and just click
Create a Connector.
Boom.
You tell it which network.
You get this default
one by default.
You're going to need
to type in an IP range
with a dash 28 CIDR range.
Just use the default one that's
in that little help text there.
And there you go.
Now you're going to
create a Redis instance.
So again, you just
click onto Memorystore.
Create it.
Give it a name.
Pick the region.
You probably want the
region to be the same one
that you picked for
App Engine, because you
want it to be in nice,
fast internet access.
And that is basically
all you want.
You could choose, there's
basic and standard tiers.
The standard tiers
have failover.
But we don't need
that for our demo.
And then we're going to
configure the app to use Redis.
That's all.
You stick that in your
production config.
Tell it use that.
And you see we're
using that Redis
URL, which I had back here in--
so back in that
app.yaml, we also
see that VPC access connector.
You have to put that in
to make the VPC work.
And then you stick in that Redis
URL at the very bottom there.
And that's the address
of the Redis instance
you just created.
And then it will all work.
All right.
So I'm not going to actually
go through all of that live,
because it takes 15 minutes.
But we can just pull
up a working app,
prove that it's working.
OK.
Can I get the--
there we go.
Cool.
So I created this app.
I'll pull it up here.
Let's make this
not terribly small.
So here's this app.
It's just a simple
app with two models.
And let's-- so here's that
app.yaml that I was showing you
before.
This is all the live stuff.
I guess it has my
credentials in it.
I'll have to destroy
this database now.
Otherwise, heaven forbid,
you could put data in there.
So that's the basic app.
And boom, it is
running right here.
You can see you get this
little appspot.com domain.
This is an app.
It tracks watches because I've
been collecting watches lately.
And it's a fun thing
to put in a database.
And you can put in
a URL, and it works.
And that is a Rails app
running on App Engine.
For some reason, it's
been super slow in the--
you can see it's
loading up right now.
I have no idea why that is.
But again, it's
alpha, so it's slow.
And man, that is really painful.
Really painful.
All right.
Well, it's not supposed
to work that way.
But the demo gods are not
looking favorably on us.
All right.
So let's switch back
into the presentation.
OK.
Again, put some
questions in Dory.
All right.
Now let's get to the fun part.
So let's look at a
world-spanning Ruby app.
Now, I think when, at
least for me, when I first
got introduced to
cloud computing,
this is what I wanted.
I wanted a cloud that
spanned the world.
And I've talked to lots
of customers of Heroku
and Google Cloud and Docker.
And there's, I'd say 1 out
of 5, maybe 1 out of 2 times,
they were like, they
say, well, can you
run it in different places?
Yes.
Can I run it in all
those places at once?
No.
It's something that's
really hard to do.
But it's something
that people want.
It's the cloud.
It's not located anywhere.
It's just kind of ephemeral.
So you want a cloud
that covers the world.
But really, you end
up getting this.
It's like, yeah.
You can put it
wherever you want.
Central, east, west--
we've got all of them.
Pick one.
So, yeah, it's great.
It's still super
awesome to not have
to manage all these
things, not have
to go down to the data center.
But it's not that
cloud of our dreams.
But it's actually
possible to build.
So let's build it.
So this is what we're
going to use for this.
Going to use the new Cloud
Run on GKE product that got
launched yesterday.
It is super cool.
If you are running Kubernetes
in your organization
but want to have a
serverless experience,
it is a smoking hot product.
You should probably
have, there's
probably someone in your
company that's the Kubernetes
operator, maybe two people.
But then you put Cloud
Run on top of it,
and you don't need to worry
about the Kubernetes stuff.
We'll also use Spanner.
So one of the hardest
parts about creating
an app in multiple
locations is the data.
It's really easy to just
run something that returns
Hello World, and that's it.
You can run that in multiple
places, but who cares?
Almost all apps need
data, and data is heavy.
And so it doesn't like
to move around a lot.
But we've got this really cool
technology called Spanner.
And we'll back it with that.
You can use Cloud Memory,
Redis, the same way
that we did in the other app.
And again, that VPC connector.
And then to wrap
it all together,
we'll use Cloudflare
to do the georouting.
Well, there was a really
cool map of the world there.
But that's not loading
for some reason.
So imagine there's a map here.
We're going to run
this in US Central
1, which is Iowa,
in EU West, which
is in Belgium, and in Asia.
It's going to be one app, three
continents, load balanced.
So it'll go to whichever
continent you are closest to.
And it'll have
automatic failover.
Here's the architecture.
So on the front, like I said,
the hard parts about this
are the load balancing
and the data.
Doing the app is
actually pretty easy.
So we'll use Cloudflare
for a geoload balancer.
Currently, the Google
Cloud load balancer
does not work well
with Cloud Run.
Hopefully, by the
end of the year,
that will not be the case.
So you could just keep it
all in the Google Cloud.
But frankly, it doesn't matter.
Cloudflare is a great product.
It worked.
It was super-- it was actually
one of the easier parts
of this whole demo to set up.
I had never done--
I'd never used this part
of Cloudflare before.
But it took me under
an hour from learning
on how to set it up.
It'll geobalance
to the code running
in any one of these
three regions.
When I made this slide, I was
going to try to use App Engine.
But it turns out Cloud Run
worked a little bit better.
The reason for that,
by the way, is you
can only have one App Engine
app per Google Cloud project.
So that makes it hard to have
an app running in three places.
You can create
multiple projects.
But then those apps can't all
connect to the same Spanner
instance, because the apps
connect to the Spanner instance
in their project.
Projects are these fenced
bounds in Google Cloud.
Then I'll have a cache layer,
and then the Spanner database
and back.
So here's some caveats.
There is no Active Record
support for Spanner.
If you google it,
you will find a gem.
It hasn't had an
update in two years.
So it's not based on
the latest Ruby version.
It's not based on the
latest Rails version.
It does actually work on the
versions that it talks about.
But it was a proof of concept.
It was built by somebody
who used to work at Google.
And it did work as
a proof of concept.
The Ruby team at
Google is hoping
to build an Active Record
adapter for Spanner
later this year.
That means that hopefully
next year, it will exist.
I would love it.
If that does exist, doing this
will become exceedingly simple,
because without
Active Record, Rails
isn't very friendly to use.
Caveat number two
is you're going
to need to use the Google
Cloud client library,
and it does not support
process forking.
Maybe you've delved into this.
But most modern servers,
they'll fork the process
and get better concurrency.
That will just break
the GRPC library, which
the cloud client's based on.
And so you just need to
set your app to not fork.
If you're using Puma, there's
a simple flag to do that.
And third caveat is, oh
my god, it is expensive.
This is not for
the faint of heart.
It is really cool.
And it's almost kind of
cool how expensive it is.
How expensive is it?
It's about a Tesla
Model 3 per month.
And that's if you use the
barest-bone configuration.
So the barest-bone
Spanner configuration
that runs on three continents
is about $27,000 per month.
Yeah, it's silly.
It's silly expensive.
The good news is, if you're
a really big company, that's
a Spanner instance.
You can have up to 100
databases on an instance.
So each database is actually
going to cost you about $270
a month, which is
super reasonable.
So if you work for a
big company and they
decide to use Spanner
for a bunch of things,
it starts to become
pretty cost-effective.
Or if you're at
really big scale.
I mean, if you're running
the next super-hot startup,
$27,000 a month to have global
reach is pretty reasonable.
There's also a
whole GKE cluster.
Each cluster in
each continent has
45 gigs of RAM and
three nodes and costs
another several thousand
dollars a month.
So it's pretty pricey.
But it's cool.
You can do it.
OK, so how do you do it?
First, you have to
create a Spanner client.
I just created that
little initializer.
And this is straight
out of the Spanner docs.
And you can see at the very end
there, the little dollar sign.
That makes it a global and to
just access this from anywhere
in your Rails app.
Then you need to populate it.
The cool thing about Spanner
is it's plain vanilla SQL.
So this is just some plain SQL.
I just created it and pasted
it in on the Spanner console
and created my table.
The app we're going to create
is just a very simple posts
app that has messages.
And like I said before, there's
no Active Record support.
Fortunately, there's this
thing in Rails now called
Active Model, which
is a lot of Active
Record without the database.
But you just need to
re-create some of the methods
that Active Record would
otherwise give you.
So what's going on here?
When I was more
ambitious, there was
an image uploaded on this app.
It didn't quite work.
We have the Active Model
in this post class.
We also have a few other
things, like these URLs helpers,
that just make things work.
Unlike an Active Record app, you
need to create this attribute
accessor.
These are just the
various attributes
that's in the database
that lets you access them.
And you can do validation.
And that's the basics
of creating a model.
Then we just need
to re-create some
of the methods Active
Record gives you.
Here's a simple finder.
You pass in an ID.
Then it just executes this
SQL, where you find a post
and return the first one.
There should only be one,
but better safe than sorry.
So that would be post.find.
Then once you have one, if
you want to save it, boom.
You just do a transaction
and insert the stuff
into the database.
I'm just passing in whatever
got set on that model.
And you could do a Find All,
where you just do a select*
and limit it to--
if you have a lot of stuff, you
don't want too many of them.
So this is re-creating
the methods
that Active Record would
give you by default.
Again, if we make an Active
Record Spanner adapter,
you won't need to do this.
It'll be really easy.
All right.
Then setting up Cloudflare.
So Cloudflare, you
just add a site.
You create these
things called pods.
Pods are nominally
collections of servers.
But since with
serverless you are
getting a collection of
servers, you basically
just map each of these to one
of your deployed instances.
And then you create
a load balancer.
And the load balancer is
just saying, load balance
between these pods.
And you can see at the very
top there, you give the URL.
In order for Cloudflare to work,
you need to be doing your DNS.
And it will automatically
create all the DNS magic.
You could also create
some health checks here
to just make sure it's working.
OK.
So let's switch into
demo mode again.
Wake up my computer.
Now, the demo gods were
not friendly to me.
And for some reason,
the-- so here's the app.
And maybe my internet's
not even working.
Oh, wait.
I see.
Wrong URL.
Boom.
All right.
So it says this app is
being served from the EU.
So the demo gods were
not friendly to me,
but it actually
helped demonstrate
some of the power of this.
For some reason, I could
not get the US version
of this app working.
Something got borked
in the configuration.
But guess what?
The Cloudflare georouting
also does failover.
So it's routing us to the
EU version of the app.
And that's basically
just pulling out
a config var that lets you know
where it's being served from,
that little message at the top.
So what this looks
like in Google Cloud--
whoa, too big.
So you go into Google
Cloud's console,
and you tap on Cloud Run.
And basically, you could
just create a service.
Actually, let's deploy.
Let's show a full deploy here.
I'm going to go to
my command line.
And here is the directory.
So here's this Hi World app.
I need to switch to the project.
So again, we talked
about those projects.
This app has its own project.
All right.
So now I'm going to
use that project.
And now I'm going to do a build.
Let's just see.
I'll just pull it out of
my command history here.
All right.
So gcloud builds submit.
And you give the tag.
So we have this other
product called Cloud Build.
And it takes a Docker file
and builds it for you.
So I just told it to
build that and tag it
with this-- gcr.io is
our container registry.
And it's going to
fetch this thing
and pull it all
up into the cloud.
You can also do the
build locally with Docker
and then just push it up there.
It actually will work
faster if you build locally,
because right now,
Cloud Build does not
cache your layers in Docker.
It just goes through all
the regular build stuff.
This is just plain
vanilla Docker.
Nothing special about this.
That's the power of Cloud Run.
Once it's built, I
can create a service.
And I just go into Cloud Run.
Here, let's start
from the beginning.
I just go into Cloud Run,
click Create Service,
pick my container image.
There we go.
Give it a name.
Now, when you pick a region,
this is Cloud Run not on GKE.
Right now, it's only
available in US central.
But then these are my GKE
clusters that I set up before.
I just pick which one I want.
Can deploy it to Asia.
And we allow it to
connect to the internet.
Optional settings.
You can pick how much memory
each instance of this app gets.
You can add any config
variables you want here.
So on this app,
I've got a region.
Click Create.
And it's going to deploy.
And that's all it takes to
deploy something to Cloud Run.
And then over here,
just to show you
what's happening in Cloudflare,
we've got this load balancer.
Is that visible?
So in Cloudflare, there's
this little traffic tab here.
And you set up a load balancer.
I've got this one.
It's hosting the demo subdomain.
And you can see it's
got two pools active.
Here's that US pool
that wasn't working.
I just turned it off because
it was having problems.
But now, it just routes to my
European pool and my Asia pool.
If we take a look
at one of those,
this is just the
default IP address
that I get on Cloud Run on GKE.
I just stuck that in there
straight out of the console.
I'll show you that.
Here's that European
version of the app.
There's that.
And I basically just copied
and pasted that into here.
And here we have the
working Hello World app.
Super small.
Wrong way.
Hello Cloud Next 2019.
Boom.
And there it is.
Hello Cloud Next.
Second time I've
made that message.
OK, it works.
Cool.
Being served from the EU because
the US is down right now.
And that's a
world-spanning Ruby app.
Can we go back to the my slides?
Thank you.
World-spanning Ruby app.
You saw it here first.
There's nothing
special about Ruby.
You could do this with,
really, any Docker container--
Node, Bash, whatever you want.
Just need to list it on port 80.
All right.
Wrapping up.
So I think one of the
points of this talk
is Google Cloud has a lot
of cool building blocks.
There's Spanner.
There's machine learning APIs.
There's all these cool things.
And what's really fun is
in just a couple of days
or a couple of hours,
depending on how good you are--
took me a couple of days because
I'm a really bad programmer--
you can snap them
together and create
something really powerful.
Second takeaway, Ruby is
on the cloud in a big way.
It's on all those services.
So if you've been waiting
to use Google Cloud
but were deterred by the lack of
Ruby support, it is there now.
And again, to try it right
now, there is the URL.
Just join that Google Group,
and you can use it today.
I would love feedback.
Just email me directly,
S-O-L-D-O at Google.
[MUSIC PLAYING]